le rappeur devenu humoriste a été révélé
par la mini série bref diffusé sur
canal+
il sera en spectacle à la ferme du
mousseau à elancourt mais également à
l'européen à paris voici kerron dans le
kiosque
bref je sais qu iron
j'ai commencé le rap pas à 16 ans
j'avais un groupe s'appelait l'arcane
dont faisait partie aujourd'hui des
créateurs de brefs naveau on s'est
retrouvé à poser des morceaux avec les
les moeurs a peur de l'époque
la brigade m'a fait rester 3 mpix 4 de
la rime sniper sully sefil état
aujourd'hui je me suis remis et je
prépare un album là pour pour l'année
prochaine qui aura des purs forcément
des choses filet et amusant dedans parce
que je suis fini amusante mais il y aura
pas de ce sera pas un album de parodies
ou alors ils allaient lui souffla qui va
confirmer et ben mazué et il y en aura
plein d'autres encore là c'est un scoop
naturel c'est parce que je suis fatigué
jamais rêvé je suis épuisé j'ai pas su
puisque je dis je donne tout en
attendant son nom et que vous dites est
tout sauf une moustache drue
c'est un enfant je peigne en corne
c'est pas un enfant
bon moment je le dis jamais vraiment été
éducateur c'est pas le travail qu'on m'a
confié n'existe pas c'était un mélange
entre l'éducateur médiateur coordinateur
et intervenants artistiques
je fais ça en quatre ans et c'était une
source extraordinaire de 2,2
d'inspiration et la salle humour
j'arrive à obtenir des choses ça fait
très peu de choses que j'aime bien
j'arrivais obtenir des choses c'est à
dire j'arrivais à à travailler avec eux
les angles dans la direction dans
laquelle je voulais les emmener pour les
aider eux mêmes et sans vouloir en fait
le soir au théâtre
j'avais la même approche avec le public
je suis devenu très pédagogique et que
le public et ça se ressent au spectacle
on dit ça c'est grâce aux enfants que
avec lesquels j'ai bossé au bâti se tape
l'affiché
en fait voilà s'il monkeys manquer d'air
on a dû revenir dessus
l'éducateur qui l'a sorti alors pour les
bébés voilà comment on sait le ca fait
plaisir
je suis regardé exactement ce qui m'a
fait aller vers le mourre moi ça a été
de jerry seinfeld
ça a été son spectacle avec lequel il
faut de la star
qui pour moi et qu'il me dise l'humour
tout simplement il ya tout ce que j'aime
dedans et ça m'a mis une claque et je
dis ça je veux le faire et après le
carton bref c'était inespéré c'est une
vitrine extraordinaire c'est comme c'est
comme le comedy club dont la brève
saperait dimension mais en gros les gens
savent que tu existes parmi les gens qui
savent que tu existes c'est ce qu'ils
disent je vais aller voir ce qu'ils font
en spectacle y viennent soit ils aiment
pas et après sa femme le bouche à
oreille et la spli gens ne reviennent
pas soit ils viennent et izm et ça fait
depuis qu'en plus il ramène du monde moi
la chance que j'ai par rapport à
l'époque du comedy club c'est que à
l'époque je n'étais pas prêt je n'avais
pas un bon spectacle du coup quand les
gens venaient moi il y avait une
pastèque en plus moi même voir sur cette
erreur c'est pas mal il a du potentiel
on verra plus tard et repartait là quand
les gens viennent ils viennent ils sont
séduits ramène du monde qui rament à
21h45 millions effectivement avec ces
deux éléments là la salle s'est remplie
puisque vous laissez ça cartoon
on a le présentateur de cinq heures dans
la salle sans mesdames et messieurs
attend le nord bien sûr
évidemment si c'est sur ma vie n'arrêtez
où l homme à femmes
n'arrêtez ou thé où elle est ni cu pour
te rencontrer je te jure c'est vrai elle
est bien que pour ça gm at il ce soir
qui sera là et toufik a nagé où il sera
et il leur avenir et la ramener vous
payez ou pas
non il existe pas la doctrine baert bien
pensante veut compter je suis fier de
mes origines je suis fier de mes racines
1 et je suis contre le racisme là moi je
suis profondément contre le racisme
contre le communautarisme est contre le
fait d'être fière de son origine ça n'a
pas de sens voilà et donc des gens qui a
facturé à midi non c'est pas vrai faut
être ok c'est ton droit de dépenser
comme ça mais je m'attaque pas au
racisme c'est comme s'attaquer à la mort
tu vois au tac à la famine
c'est pourquoi s'attaquer à la famine ça
n'a pas de sens et je m'attaque pour
racisme j'essaie de au contraire de le
comprendre pour mieux le combattre
je pense sincèrement que que qu'il faut
prendre le contre-pied pour pour pour
marquer les gens et quitta les choquer
et ensuite pour le faire réfléchir même
si le spectacle n'a pas vocation à faire
réfléchir
chico's gros chèque ou tu veux pas
partie de l'amérique l'asie c'est ça je
sens arabi conçu par la demande non pas
les avoir si les lapins du pauvre en
fait j'adore nous faire croire qu'à
l'origine les colombiennes non non il va
devoir s'attaquer à l'arrêt
et quelle origine chico bien sûr chico
j'aime bien j'y crois car dans un
théâtre il s'est mis à me tim morris est
qu elle va dans une boulangerie ce mode
cross en effet sa réaction moi je suis
une efficacité
j'ai pris tous mes sketches tout ce que
j'ai écrit quatre ans de matériel
j'ai tout testé sur des scènes j'ai
gardé ce qui marche le plus après comme
je suis quelqu'un qui réfléchit dans la
vie j'essaie d'être pédagogique ça se
ressent sur scène mais à aucun moment je
me dis je vais les faire réfléchir les
gens et je veux qu'ils sortent en se
disant j'ai une autre vision du monde
pas du tout c'est que l'efficacité
si demain sur mes mille blague il y en a
celles qui marchent plus et les blagues
sur les pets jeffrey dix minutes de paix
et après qu iron une autre star je sais
que tu l'attends public elle est là
spécialement pour toi voici johanna
soudry avec un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction dans le kiosque le mec il
m'attrape par le goût de la cac mirow a
perdu la vue il y a dix huit ans atteint
d'une dégénérescence de la rétine
il quitte alors son métier de
kinésithérapeute et décide de se lancer
dans le spectacle pour proposer un
humour pédagogique
j'explique j'explique en fait comment ça
se passe avec un chien et puis après
comment ça se passe avec une canne et
après ça ce comment ça se passe quand on
est mal voyants mais tout ça en fait
c'est pédagogique instructif jeu à
prendre le bus c'est hongrie pas pour
rire mais on rit pour apprendre fait je
me sers du rire comme moyen
d'apprentissage mais pas en voyant la
photo
cette année miro celui revue rassure la
sienne de la royale factory dans le
cadre du festival orphée festivals
européens avec un théâtre et handicap on
peut travailler avec des personnes
handicapées faire un travail
professionnel de qualité et c'est aussi
le but du festival orphée j'ai mis en
adéquation ce qu est l art souvent dans
la défense des causes perdues
justement avec des gens dont on dit que
la cause est perdue c'est ça aussi la
grande force croix du projet aurélie
seedorf est aussi ses dettes dans la
réalité on fait avec les gens on
n'assiste pas les gens fait avec eux
michel reynaud directeur artistique du
festival
met aussi en scène et comédiens du
théâtre eurydice un esat basé sur
plaisir ils présenteront une adaptation
des exercices de style de raymond
queneau au théâtre montansier qu'est ce
que vous ressentez vous impressionner
j'ai beaucoup de trac et puis j'ai
toujours le trac avant puis là c'est
encore plus impressionnant parce que
faire avec la fal les spectateurs l'an
de spectateurs c'est impressionnant
ah bah déjà là j'ai comme le disait mon
si j'ai besoin de reconnaissance donc
c'est important pis ça m'a permis aux
débuts de essentielle la timidité parce
que j'étais très timide et puis ça me
permet d'être en confiance en moi aussi
et puis ça m'a permis de l'oci d'être
appelés sur scène et ce qui est génial
la dixième édition du festival orphée
s'ouvrira vendredi 28 septembre pour
s'achever samedi 20 octobre
le programme complet est à retrouver sur
internet est encore quelques dates à
retenir avant d'aller à votre cours de
zumba le 5 octobre la grande sophie sur
un concert au scarabée le 6 octobre
c'est la nuit blanche à saint quentin en
yvelines avec des danseurs des
spectacles des plasticiens et des
visites avoir à faire et à admirer dans
le quartier 17 mars à elancourt et ceux
de 19h à minuit les places de bel ébat à
guyancourt cette soirée vous proposera
de prendre la prose avec les poètes à
l'occasion d'une nuit blanche de la
poésie le 13 octobre vous retrouverez le
sébastien l'ado new quartet à l'occasion
du premier jazz club de la saison au
prisme le 13 octobre toujours les fans
de rock se rendront au festival food
rock à manier les mots afin d'applaudir
entre autres acmé et et charger
des dates que vous pouvez retrouver
ainsi que l'ensemble de la programmation
culturelle des salles saint-quentinoise
dans le kiosque sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affiche alors bon
spectacle à tous et à bientôt